ALL-STAR BREAK BOTH ERE'S NOT A
THERE,  THE 8th TIME THEY
HAVE HAD WITH WHAT THEY HAVE
CONSID THE TEAM.
THEY THOUGHTND IT WENT OFF THE
SHOULDER OF SOROKOK AND IT
KEEPS GOING OVER THE SHOULDER.
YOU SEE ON THE
STICK.
SHOWINGND FORSBERG MAKES
THE GLOVE STOP.
>> YOU CANNOT PUT THEAWAY.
THIS IS NOT THE  FORWARDS ON "D
ON.
HERE IS TIERNEY.
STUMBLES AND KEEP IT FROM
TIERNEY. THE  BEEN --
>> YOU HAVE THE TEAM.
THERE'S NELSON OFF THE JACK
CAPUANOO FOR HIM
EARLY ENOUGH TO REALIZE HOW OPE.
BEAUVIVIFORSBERG. NOTHAT IS BLO.
BAILEY.
A LOOSE IT.
LOOK AT THIS, ONE, IGNED A CONTO
STAY ON LONG ISLAND.
>> L.
>> ONE TIPPED DOWN BY DRAINED R.
>> OTTAWA GOES TO ANOTHER
CHANGE.
AND THE SITUATION.LEE.
MAYFIELD, ACROSS, BARZAL, HE TH.
>> THAT WAS AARON TRYING FOOL
US. THERE TOGETHER.
>> P AND P.
>> THE OTHER P AND P.
>> YEAH.
>> WORKIKI
TIME-OUT ON THE
GOOD PLAYERS.
MAYFIELD WITH THE SECOND ASSIST.
HEADS UP PLAY.
"D" TOE
ICE.